Speaker 1: The United States has now officially
said we do not believe that the recent surveillance
balloons slash devices tentatively believed
to be from China are evidence of intelligent
aliens from another planet, solar system or
galaxy even visiting us on Earth.
Joe Biden's press secretary, Karine Jean-Pierre,
making that statement during a press briefing
yesterday.
Speaker 2: We addressed this from the White
House.
I know there have been questions and concerns
about this, but there is no, again, no indication
of aliens or extraterrestrial activity with
these recent takedowns.
Again, there is no indication of aliens or
terrestrial actors.
Speaker 1: It's funny because the press corps
laughs.
But just look online.
There are endless gobs of people convinced
that this is a cover up of extraterrestrial
encounters.
Speaker 2: But with these recent takedowns,
we wanted to make sure that the American people
knew that.
All of you knew that.
And it was important for us to say that from
here, because we.
Speaker 1: Sure careen That's just what you
would say if you wanted to cover it up.
Speaker 2: Hearing a lot about it.
I'm not.
Speaker 3: Jealous.
Speaker 2: I'm just, you know, I loved E.T.,
the movie, but I'm going I'm just going to
leave it there.
Speaker 1: All right.
The National Security Council's John Kirby
also reiterated this and said this.
These are not aliens.
It's not aliens, folks.
Speaker 3: The top officials in the Pentagon,
when asked explicitly if they were ruling
out any kind of extraterrestrial presence,
that they weren't doing anything out.
And yet at the beginning of today's briefing,
albeit with her usual winning smile, Ms..
Jean-Pierre seemed to rule out any extraterrestrial
activity.
Speaker 2: I don't think the American people
need to worry about aliens with respect to
these craft.
Period.
Speaker 1: I don't think there's any.
Now, you heard what he said, right?
I don't think the American people need to
worry about aliens with respect to these craft.
And there are those who believe that Kirby
is very narrowly answering this question and
saying these are not extraterrestrial aliens.
But that doesn't mean that there aren't others.
Now, let's talk a little bit about aliens.
This is this is a very interesting topic.
I want to expand on what I said during my
recent appearance with Anthony Pompliano when
I was down in Florida.
One of the appearances I did was with Anthony
Pompliano, and he asked me about aliens.
It is really important to understand the sheer
vastness of the universe.
You've got our galaxy, the Milky Way, hundreds
of billions of stars, and then all of the
accompanying planets and so on and so forth.
So I do have a very general view that based
on what we know about the vastness of the
universe, statistically, I think the likelihood
of extraterrestrial life of some kind could
be bacterial, could be intelligence.
I don't know.
I think the odds are high.
The probability of that intelligent life having
already visited Earth, I believe, is extraordinarily
low.
And the sort of math of it is as follows.
You look at the number of stars in the universe,
it's astronomical.
100 billion in our own Milky Way alone.
With that number of stars, it is likely that
at least some planets would be capable of
supporting life.
So the conditions, at least theoretically
for life, are probably not that rare.
If you look at all of the planets that there
are, you then say, okay, well, on some fraction
of those that could support life, it doesn't
seem super unlikely, even if it's a small
percentage that life would develop.
And so I do think that when you consider all
of that and the age of the universe, 13.8
billion years old, that's a lot of time for
life to have evolved on other planets as well.
So I think it is likely, given the laws of
physics and chemistry, which appear to be
universal and all these different things,
it's likely that there is life on other planets.
Do I think it has reached Earth in the form
of a balloon or a cylinder or, you know, humanoid
four foot tall aliens with obsessed with anal
probes?
It must be proctology, must be big on other
planets.
I don't know that I don't have any evidence
for.
And then when you look at the numerous so-called
UFO sightings over the years, we have a lack
of concrete evidence.
We see that the stories that are told match
the images of supposed aliens from movies
and from popular culture, and many are specifically
debunked as aircraft or weather balloon or
birds or whatever.
So, you know, there's that there's the lack
of physical evidence in all of these different
things.
So really funny coda to this, which is Mark
Esper, Trump's former secretary of defense,
who says, you know, if aliens were to come
here, I don't think this is exactly what they
would do.
Careful.
Speaker 4: I'm confident saying that I doubt
that the aliens would travel across the universe
and all of a sudden decide to conduct surveillance
over Lake Huron in a balloon moving 20 miles
per hour.
That's a plan that I think we're in good shape
and we now know we can shoot them down.
But I don't think that's true at all.
Look, my hunch is that these are weather balloons
or scientific experiments put off by another
country, another company or some nonprofit.
We'll learn that in due course.
Speaker 1: Yeah, I you know, I it makes sense.
Esper is not a guy that I found super interesting
as an elected official or whatever, But I
do think this is a good point.
And it's similar to, you know, if if the aliens
really were making contact, I don't know that
their priority would necessarily be anal probes.
And so it's sort of weird that that's a big
part of a lot of the stories that are.
I think Esper is right, but maybe that's just
what the aliens want us to think.
It's not us because we would never just go
20 miles an hour over one of the Great Lakes.
Let me know what you think.
I agree with Karine Jean-Pierre and Kirby
and Esper.
I do not believe this is evidence of alien
contact.